I'm Jeff hennig
professor of political science and
education
Teachers College Columbia
and I'm
serving as the moderator for this panel
we've got a presentation a three-person
presentation and then we're going to
have a short comment afterwards let me
introduce the panelists and then I'll
turn it over to them Arthur Vanderveen
is CEO of the office of innovation in
New York's Department of Education and
in this role he's leading an initiative
to engage 400 schools in a three year
process of reorganizing themselves
around personalized models of learning
prior to this he managed the
administration and development of the
department's portfolio of summative and
formative assessments he also directs
the department's education technology
and knowledge management initiatives
from 2003 to 2007 he held several
positions at the College Board where he
helped lead the design and development
of the College Board's comprehensive
reform model Arthur received his BA from
Colorado College in 1985 his master of
divinity from Princeton Theological
Seminary in 1989 and his PhD in english
from the university of texas at austin
in 2002 he's the author of numerous
articles and chapters and presentations
on college readiness assessment design
comprehensive school reform academic
content standards curriculum development
and alignment methodologies Alyssa
burger is founding co-principal at the
New York City High School which is one
of the new york city public high schools
previously she worked in the New York
City Department of Education central
office as a director of leadership and
organizational learning where she
oversaw 250 schools in reaching the goal
of increased student achievement and did
so by developing an aligning and
delivering cutting-edge train
and professional development tools these
tools included the children's first
intensive and action research initiative
designed to help build schools capacity
to use accountability tools to
differentiate individualize and improve
instruction she also served as a
facilitator for the scaffolded
apprenticeship model a master's degree
program run through Baruch College which
is far city university system she began
her career in school administration as
the founding leader of the Mott Hall to
school a small progressive New York City
public school Anna Goldman is a third
grade teacher at CS 154 the Harriet
Tubman Learning Center she began her
career at PS 125 the Ralph Bunche school
mark making this her 10th year teaching
in the Harlem community born and raised
in Upper Manhattan she attended to new
york city public schools throughout her
life so she can probably provide a
better historical perspective than
almost any of the speakers we've heard
today her educational experience
includes a BA in sociology and a
certificate in african-american studies
from the university of maryland and an
MS masters in teaching from Pace
University and then we're going to at
the end of the the presentation which is
co-ordinated we're going to hear from
laura marcilio who is Commissioner for
education family and youth of the
municipality of Rome a position she's
held since 2008 the city of Rome has
direct jurisdiction over early childhood
education up to six years old and
provides a support role for compulsory
education the city of Rome has
established educational programs to
increase cultural awareness and civic
pride amongst youth and initiatives have
been launched to increase the physical
activity
students in primary schools as well as
provide them access to nutrition base
curricula and activity I think if I
understand it correctly she'll be
speaking more to explain some of those
initiatives that she's involved in
although she's listed as a commentator I
think it will be more in that role than
commenting on the papers themselves and
with that i'm going to introduce arthur
who's going to start the presentation
Thank You professor hennig good
afternoon everyone hope to keep you
awake for the last part of the afternoon
hope you all had a chance to get some
coffee I certainly did and we are very
excited to share with you some of the
work we're doing here in New York City
around innovation in our schools and our
office the office of innovation was
started about a year ago a little over a
year ago you may have heard Chancellor
Klein mentioned he felt innovation was
something he wish he had started earlier
and though he's been innovating and the
system's been innovating for the last
eight years having a dedicated team of
folks looking at new school models many
of which leverage technology in order to
accelerate student achievement that
became the charge of this new office and
we've been working for the last year
identifying creative new innovations
both within and beyond city of New York
and identifying schools in networks of
schools doing this creative work and
framing out a plan for the next three
years to try some very creative and
innovative stuff so that is the very
privileged position that I get to do
working in this very dynamic and
creative city of New York and it's been
a thrill to be a part of this we've
heard all day long I think everyone's
making the case for change but it's
something that we do remind ourselves of
why are we even here why are we thinking
what further needs to be done because
we've made a lot of progress in the last
eight years in New York City but one
thing I like to consider is that a
system and the Chancellor talked about a
systemic approach to this work thinking
in terms of systems systems are designed
to produce the outcomes that they
produce so if we're now producing a
sixty-three percent graduation rate we
can ask ourselves is this system that
we're currently using capable of doing
much much more than that we are being
faced with new higher expectations here
in the US and in state of New York with
the common core standards coming if
you've had a chance to look at them they
are indeed much more rigorous demanding
of our students they'll be in place in
the coming two years in addition to that
a set of new assessments that are coming
through a consortium that are much more
rigorous in terms of their focus on
application richer set of performances
much more challenging than the
standardized assessments that we've been
using in the past most recently here in
New York State the cut scores on our
exams were adjusted to reflect those
students who are actually graduating and
prepared to perform in college at a
college ready rate it's had dramatic
impacts on the ratings of our schools
and the percents of percentage of
students who are actually graduating
ready we know there is a lot more that
we need to do and so are charged in the
office of innovation is to think about
can we wholly rethink the system it's
one of the nice advantages were given to
think in wholly new ways and then begin
to translate that into new practices new
school models new uses of technology to
try to achieve really significant
dramatic new gains that we need to
achieve if we're going to be successful
with our students so we start with kind
of a baseline understanding of the
nature of school today
those of you are any history of
Education know are modeled arrived very
much from an end of the 19th century
model that came out of the progressive
tradition that is strong emphasis on
standardization we were looking for
standard models standard teacher
criteria standard definitions of what's
called a Carnegie unit enough seat time
to justify granting of credit standard
length of day standard length of school
year tremendous tremendous focus on
standardization that's been the defining
model for our schools since the late
19th century and so you hear stories we
hear the Chancellor often saying if you
were to fall asleep 100 years ago and
then wake up and walk into a classroom
today it would not be much different
than what was seen at the last turn of
the century not this most recent one as
we think about then innovation we've
started to think about what would really
be that Copernican shift that paradigm
shift what would move us beyond the
system as it's designed today in
producing sixty-three percent graduation
rates to really something wholly new as
we've thought about this over the last
year talking with our schools talking
with experts from around the world and
the crud the country we've come to this
idea of a fulcrum of really shifting the
relationship from teacher to student in
in their relationship to content in
learning if we can move to a radically
student-centered model that puts the
student at the center of their learning
empowers them to be directing their
learning responsible for their learning
self managing in their learning with all
the records that supports that's
required to achieve that what would the
implications be for the way we think
about school with that shift we came to
a model that we call personalized
mastery learning so it's a best
descriptive it's not the best it's not
the most catchy of phrases but we do
think it describes kind of the nature of
a school that makes this radical shift
to
strongly student-centered model there
we've identified five design principles
of a school that we think reflects this
shift starts off with globally
competitive standards in New York State
in fact nationally we are all moving
toward common core 4343 of our 50 states
are moving to common core but it's more
than just that it's it's an openness to
looking at other international
frameworks looking at tims and pieces
international benchmarks for our work
looking at standards for 21st century
learning identifying those kind of
cognitive skills that Alex shubh was
describing yesterday that they were
targeting for their graduates in terms
of critical thinking problem solving
problem formation creativity
collaboration that set of skills that
are much more rigorous and require a
very different model of teaching and
learning if we are going to develop
those capacities and our students that
we know are critical to succeed in a
21st century workplace and in college
personalized learning plans are another
critical piece of this we want to move
to where each of our schools has a
personalized learning plan for every
student really thinking about and
understanding where is each of our
students on their learning pathways and
how can we begin to design curriculum
instruction learning opportunities and
assessments that take them where they
are and move them forward at their
optimal pace through their optimal
pathway we've looked at models that are
out there we've been scanning and
searching and we found examples both in
New York City and nationally and
internationally we have one partner that
we're going to be working with is a
school management organization in Sweden
called Koontz copskalyn very interesting
model that we're looking at they work
with their students in an advisory model
where for every student they're
developing out a six-year plan to move
from sixth grade to high school
graduation annual goals for each of
those students monthly goals
weekly goals teachers then advised
students 25 students and teams to help
them self manage and self direct against
that goal setting and planning across
the entire course of their career that
kind of personalization is the kind of
dramatic change that we think is
critical to this work once you make that
shift and you actually have students
owning responsibility for defining the
pathway and the pace of their own
learning it has strong implications for
the roles of teachers and all of the
staff in the school as well as a student
we haven't been training our students to
think about being responsible for their
own learning we haven't put them in that
position of empowerment and
responsibility because our 19th century
model puts them in a much more passive
role where they are receiving and then
responding back to us in fairly
superficial ways what it is that we're
expecting of them making that shift will
have dramatic effects on the role of the
teacher and then beyond that the way we
organize the teachers role the teachers
time teacher relationships with students
that one fulcrum we think is critical to
the organizational model for the entire
school if we're going to expect these
higher capacities of our students that
include the higher-order thinking skills
creativity and collaboration that we
think is important we need to begin
assessing these skills in new and
creative ways so another critical
principal to our work is the use of
performance assessments it's Richard
performance assessments that in fact are
going to become part of the state's
accountability model by 2014 here in New
York State we are moving to that kind of
assessment model formative assessment
model now creating much richer
performance tasks that expect enable and
expect students to demonstrate actual
competencies rather than just spending
fifty four hours in a semester in order
to earn a semester links credit for a
course
in addition to that as your as you're
identifying learning pathways for every
student and their progressively
demonstrating that competency or those
proficiencies you're moving them through
on their own pace and that mastery based
grading is around each student's
individual learning pathway and finally
the last design principle that we're
following is this idea of multiple
learning modalities and we anchor are
thinking about that in the nature of a
21st century workplace when you think of
the way that we work today it's entirely
in teams around projects with defined
timelines and deliverables the
boundaries of those teams are flexible
we identify people that we need to bring
expertise and information we use
technology to collaborate to communicate
we give feedback to one another we don't
work in standard periods of 42 minutes a
day and set kind of weekly curriculum
that's just not the nature of the 21st
century workplace so we want to
translate into our school environment
models from 21st century workplace where
students are working in teams they're
working one-to-one they're working in
large groups they're working with
experts beyond the school that kind of
flexibility is critical not only for
preparing them for the environments
they'll be working in when they graduate
but also because of the engagement when
you enable students to work more
flexibly that way and obviously you can
see the kind of responsibility you're
putting on students and teams of
students when they need to begin working
this way it's also empowering them in
the level of engagement increases
dramatically so all five of these taken
together are kind of the design
principles that we're setting out to
engage what will be 200 schools over the
next three years to develop a blueprint
for how they will realize this vision of
personalized mastery learning in their
schools
this is a big challenge that we've set
for ourselves and we know we can't do
this on our own so we have a strong
effort to recruit partners who have
experience in doing this kind of work
who can work with our schools to engage
in this three-year plan our steps in
this process are to recruit right now
we're recruiting our networks in schools
who believe that this approach to
teaching and learning will really
achieve this the much more dramatic
outcomes that they're targeting as we
recruit those networks in schools in
parallel we're recruiting a portfolio of
partners who can work with us partners
like Koontz copskalyn who have
experience in running schools around
these kinds of personalized mastery
learning models by January we will be
brokering partnerships between these
partners in our networks of schools and
they together will enter into a co
design process between january and march
to develop out their blueprint in their
three-year roadmap for how they will
realize this vision that roadmap will
include prototyping specific components
this is not something you can ingest
that you can take on immediately in a
few months this is going to be a long
process three-year commitment and so
developing out the sequencing of how
schools will move to this new model
they'll be prototyping components of
this and we'll be supporting that
prototyping we use that phrase
intentionally with strong evaluation
around which of these components is
working is it feasible can it be
implemented is it having impacts on
student engagement and on student
outcomes what are the implications for
our schools capacity our teachers
capacity to work in these ways lots of
evaluation not in the sense of program
evaluation but more in terms of Rd
research and development testing these
components and then progressively
building them together into this
coherent model so that by the end of
three years there is community level
commitment to this work our model for
scale is also built in from the
in New York City were organized with
around networks of schools 20 to 25
schools who have affiliated around a
common vision pedagogical philosophy
shared view on their work and have
existing mechanisms for sharing
knowledge and sharing practice as we
move into this work we're not recruiting
individual schools we're recruiting
networks those networks will identify
five schools who will come out of the
gate starting with this work in March
with that design and planning and then
launching next fall and they'll have
five affiliate schools who will be kind
of in the wings learning about this
process as they come online in 2012 and
then those ten schools will have 10
affiliate schools who will also be in
the wings learning and then coming
online in 2013 but it's the role of the
network to facilitate that diffusion in
scale supporting that transfer of
practice and we use a model of
communities of practice communities of
engagement and communities of interest
to facilitate that diffusion across the
entire network
there's both a push and a poll to this
work building capacity investing is a
critical piece of this and so we know we
need to build the capacity of our
networks and schools to take on this
innovative work so new school leaders is
a big part of this incubating new school
leaders out of these schools that are
doing this work and enabling them to
create new schools along these models
within these networks increasing the
level of support that we're getting from
networks bringing in these innovation
partners from outside of the school
system working on the community and
family investment in this work and then
critical technology tools these are all
the conditions and capacities are the
capacities that are required to support
this work briefly around some of those
tools we've identified online learning
is a critical piece to this enabling
these schools to incorporate online
learning flexibly to support those
personalized learning plans for every
student scheduling that comes around
that another critical piece to this is
what we call our mastery tracker which
is right now nothing more than a concept
but we're looking for providers who may
be able to provide this for us if you're
talking about personalized learning
plans for every student and they're
demonstrating mastery from a variety of
different learning opportunities
performance tasks portfolios that all
has to be mapped to a competency
framework and progressively showing
developing mastery across that framework
over time we need a tool that enables us
to do that so that we can bring together
those richer assessments in a way that
it's progressively building toward
demonstrated mastery we think
eportfolios is a fundamental part of
this work the scheduling that's required
to support students working in these
multiple modalities in the performance
assessments this right now is the kind
of fundamental technology platform that
we're will be prototyping parts of this
in building toward an enterprise level
on the other side in order to create the
pull are the
policies the policy aspect of this
that's also critical and so moving away
from seat time moving toward
demonstrated mastery as a Chancellor
referenced this morning critical piece
to this and we're working with the state
on allowing us to pilot these models
that allow students to earn credits
based on demonstrated mastery rather
than see time accountability is a
critical piece of this right now we
operate under a very high stakes model
with our school progress reports quality
reviews we're looking into how can we
create a safer place for these schools
to pilot new practices that may not
produce results in the first year and so
we want to create an environment where
they're not penalized for that
risk-taking as I said this has
implications for our staffing or teacher
roles are titles and we're looking at
new titles new teacher roles and how
that can be supported in negotiation
with the Union and then funding models
one critical piece of this in New York
State we have a pretty strong funding
stream around textbooks we'd like to
find greater flexibility and using those
funds not just for printed text books
but also for digital resources and
computers as we move into a 21st century
model of teaching and learning here's
our goals for transforming the system of
schools we have what I've been
describing are the Izone schools which
is this whole school transformation in
our goal by 2013 to have 200 schools on
a pathway toward this whole school
transformation in parallel to this is
our online learning work which we call i
learn NYC which will be supporting those
200 Izone schools but will also be
expanding otherwise to another 240
schools so that within three years we
have 440 schools on this pathway toward
much more personalized mastery-based
learning so that's the context for our
work really am most excited to let you
hear from a principal and a teacher
who've been engaged in this work and can
give you kind of the feel for how this
looks on the ground thank you
yeah I'm gonna say this is on in 2008 we
were asked to start a high school
charged with rethinking high school for
the 21st century with the notion that
the Chancellor said that if people woke
up after 150 years sleep they wanted to
walk into our high school and see
something completely different and what
we knew was that while in a lot of
places in America we talked about seeing
something really different means you see
a lot of technology that rethinking high
school was not about putting a lot of
technology in place it was about
rethinking what when where and how we
teach students and how students are
experiencing learning so our charge was
to rethink all of those things and
assume nothing because that's how it's
been done since the beginning and
question everything that we do and and
while we were charged with doing this it
was a very explicit chart that the DOA
is wonderful at creating amazing schools
individual amazing schools but this was
about transforming a system and so that
nothing we were supposed to do in our
school would be unlockable across a
larger system and and the school was set
up with supports from central office in
order to create and I school that parts
of it could be spread out across the
system the whole model could be taken to
other schools and that we could really
have a spread of innovation across the
system and we started this an
environment that the Chancellor had
already set up where as principals we
had complete autonomy over what we could
do that we could teach you while we have
state standards how we address those
standards was completely up to us that
we were going to be held accountable for
very specific student achievement
results but how we achieve those student
adults was up to us and with a very
conscious notion from the the
chancellor's office on down that it was
our job to find where we were getting
stuck and that they would move the
system for us so when we hit a block
with a state regulation we went to the
office and said we can't do what we know
is another student's best interest and
they helped us as much as they could to
find workarounds for all of those blocks
and then enabled us to come up with a
very unique instructional model our
students spend a portion of their time
each day doing what we call
individualized learning what Arthur
calls personalized learning it's when
students work at their own pace and I
work with 14 to 18 year old so their own
pace is not actually their own pace but
it is an individualized pace that is
supported by a teacher to achieve the
requirements that they need to graduate
high school in New York State we have
Regents exams so our students take
online individualized courses to move
themselves through the content and
skills they need to do well on these
exams and that each student is
experiencing a different online
classroom based on his or her individual
needs and students spend different
amount of times in these online classes
based on prior of knowledge skill and
efficacy be in going through these
courses these we are able to
individualize at a very low data point
level so that we can really target
students where they need the support and
the content knowledge and allow them to
skip the areas of where they already
have content knowledge through this we
dramatically accelerate how our students
experience the new york state curriculum
the majority of our students complete
all their requirements at the end of
10th grade in two years rather than in
the four years it takes most students to
do that but but this that our online
learning component does not address what
we talked about is the 21st century
skills it does not teach them their
higher order thinking skills it does not
teach them the collaborative skills it
does not teach them problem-solving
skills creative thinking skills all of
the skills that we talk about this
students needing to be successful in
college and in in when they graduate
from college
and so students work on that part of our
curriculum and what we call learning
modules these are nine week challenge
base units where our students work as
consultants to nonprofits private
companies and public organizations
throughout the city and the world and
learn through doing actual work that
organizations need to be done get done
so for example there is an organization
called the National September 11th
memorial and museum it is a museum that
will open at Ground Zero at some point
in the future and they have professional
exhibit designers and one of the
permanent exhibits at this museum when
it opens is going to be an adolescent
exhibit and the exhibit designers came
to us there are a staff of three at the
Museum that we in order to design a good
exhibit you need to know what students
are what kids are walking into the
exhibit thinking about 911 and you can't
unless you know what people know and
think you can't design a good exhibit
but we know we're going to be an
international museum and we have no way
of finding out what kids around the
world think about 911 and luckily I have
a consulting staff of hundreds so in our
class we studied 911 we put it in
historical context going back to the
Crusades we studied in social studies
the notion of context that in in the
sciences we talk to students about doing
an experiment and everyone observing
that experiment is supposed to see the
exact same thing and in the social
sciences what we talked about how nobody
interprets the same event the same way
and that's because of our a religious
background or ethnic background a
political background all of the context
that goes into making how we define a
group and our students picked a place in
the world and they de studied what about
that place might someone from there
inform their context of how they
perceive 911 then they video conference
with students from that place talking to
them about their understanding of what
were the events that led up to 911 what
actually happened on that day
what were the ramifications and turned
those interviews in two monologues which
they then reported back to museum the
museum had a hundred different
perspective of composite children from
around the world that are actually now
part of museum archives and on display
at the the tribute Center which is what
the museum currently has standing and
our kids talk to kids in London who
talked about the relationship between
the US and Britain going back
historically they talked about what was
going on in the router Iraq war and the
support that that US was getting and
they talked about the London bombing and
their experience with with terrorism on
this level and we talked to kids in
Israel who talked about terrorism being
a regular part of life and and that
informed how they viewed it and
transformed how our kids see a whole
part of the world and and kids talk to
people kids who look to just like them
and in in Saudi Arabia who talked about
what 911 was like that day was like in
their country which was very different
from what we experienced is New Yorkers
and they even talked to American kids in
Mississippi and Louisiana who talked
about the government response to
Hurricane Katrina and and that was
informing how they talked about 911 so
our students are able to learn a lot of
that about their their environment to
study the notion of of social context
and understanding parts of the world and
how they fit together and interact in a
way that is engaging and thoughtful and
real-world to them the other element we
use is distance learning extensively so
we do believe that the notions that
there are teachers out there who are
experts and that our students can use
technology to engage with them on a real
basis our students you know the
Chancellor talked at lunch about the AP
conversation with the state and our
students do take AP classes virtually in
another school I think all of this was
was enabled by within the school a
system that allowed for a co leadership
model we are the only cool
in the in the entire system and the
Chancellor saying you can innovate at
every part of the organization and a
real public-private partnership that we
were started with a partnership with
cisco systems where we were really
working together to solve these problems
and using real-world models and in
outside the school an environment that
truly encouraged innovation where we
were told we could take risks and we
could fail and that and that was okay
and having very clear benchmarks for
success so when even people questioned
what we were doing because there were
these citywide accepted standards for
success that when people knew we were
successful even if sometimes our methods
were questioned and the ability to
really be very public and supported by
by the system above us for what we were
doing so that's how we used innovation
at the school level thank you okay mine
on soon every community as you set up to
10 years here in Harlem currently I'm at
127 street and most of my students in
grade 3 4 and 5 all have a real variety
of academic social and emotional needs
and from the beginning of teaching 10
years ago I've been trying to help 21st
century learners and keep the classroom
and exciting place and I've always done
that with no more than three or four
desktop computers in the classroom and
real basic technology this year as a
result of a lot of what Arthur spoke
about my classroom is a part of
something called the Izone so in
addition to a smart board a projector
and a laptop that I have is the teacher
we have 20 netbooks in the classroom and
i can tell you has completely
transformed the classroom so I think the
best way to explain and what I can share
is just to give some examples during a
literacy black we are studying and
author nikki grimes who has written
several different books about the
african-american experience here in
Harlem and one of the children we start
talking about how to gather more
information about Nicky Grimes so of
course with them
moments woman wants to take out a
netbook starts to research Nikki Grimes
after this child does that she then I
bring her up to the front she uses my
laptop to broadcast on the smartboard
the steps that she's taken to research
this author now during social studies
this child and another child are going
to lead a research group with 12
netbooks in the back while I get to work
in the front with our text which is on a
third grade level most of our students
are not on a third grade level so I'm
now working with a group of 10 students
while two students are leading their own
group of six students and all this is
happening at the same time and what's
really exciting for me about it is it's
an example of how taking a part of our
curriculum comes to life and also the
children do this in in school and then
go and can do it in their local
libraries and they can do it at home
another example we have a childhood just
came from Yemen this year speaks no
English I'm able to assign him work on
the netbook with software that comes
with the the netbooks compass learning
is called offers language arts and
mathematics activities for the children
I have access to work grades K through I
think we have access k through 5 so I
have this child on a netbook with
phonemic awareness and basic alphabet
skills while other children are using
the same device to do second or third or
fourth grade work on a topic that they
need help on and I heard you talk about
on the high school level the idea of
being able to meet the child where they
are give them practice on what they need
so they're not learning things that they
already know and they're also able to
use what they're good at to help their
classmates and that's one of the most
exciting things I've seen is the
children really step up to take their
own leadership with the netbooks I have
a child who is an academic struggler
himself who works with this child who
just came from Yemen and I've watched
him become so much more confident in his
own academics because he's able now to
be someone who's explaining something to
someone else as opposed to most of his
educational experiences being the one
there at the bottom of the class was
always saying he doesn't know what's
going on
we have students in the classroom who
are performing above grade level these
students are doing above grade level
work where they can and they also work
as monitors throughout the classroom to
assist other students who are struggling
with the work that they're doing using
the computer whether it's as a research
group or doing the assign work to
compass learning another thing that
compass learning offers is the child
themselves since they each log into
their own account can monitor their own
progress by clicking on what's called a
backpack and seeing okay the teacher
assignment is scale I'm practicing it
they can look at how they did on it and
even go in and reassign the activity to
themselves so I have a system in place
for them to assess themselves on a
weekly basis and say okay out of
everything that I've been asked to do
this week what do I need now to do to be
sure that I can show that I've really
mastered a skill it's a challenging job
being a teacher because it's our job to
take all of this policy and all of these
changes which i know we say there's many
things that haven't changed but in ten
years of teaching I've seen a whole lot
change every single year but you know
these changes come in the tools to
really make these changes possible don't
always come and for me that's what's so
exciting about being part of the Izone
is having this class set of netbooks so
that when a real question emerges out of
a real conversation we actually have a
tool to turn around and take a next step
with it and I'm very very excited as to
how this new initiative as transform my
classroom and really allowed me to keep
up with children in a way that I haven't
been able to before and I really
appreciate the opportunity also to be
here because as a teacher we're not
always given the opportunity to step out
of the classroom and see what's
happening on even our own city level let
alone an international level so I think
it's all very very exciting and the most
exciting thing to me is really having an
opportunity to get the tools and and
make make a reality of a lot of the
policy
that we talked about and we hear about
so I hope that we will continue to be
eyes on school and I hope that I will
find that many other classrooms so I
think about six of our classrooms in my
school now but many other classrooms
across the city will have the
opportunity because it's difficult to
keep up with a 21st century learner
without 21st century tools so thank you
very much I very helpful in this in this
panel to see something from the ideas
all the way down to the actual
implementation of plenty of time for
questions but before we do we have a
comment from Commissioner marcilio from
Rome lat co depressed Oviedo oportunidad
Egan front arch in questa conferenza
Internationale the opportunity to share
in this international conference to
exchange experience views and learn
about other people's ended the
experiences in order to move towards
innovation and motivate our children to
achieve their objectives through their
school education is vital Roma capitale
the Italian the Roman municipality is
dealing limited to this and in a
framework where the central government
assess the overall and
recruiting personnel and the current
government is promoting our reform which
is in line with what bloomberg new york
mayor said earlier today we're talking
about a motivation accountability
remoting married and promoting new
assessment systems so i think that our
countries or i mean your country and
italy Lord is New York administration
and the Roman administration are
definitely moving in the same direction
within this overall framework Rome is
focusing on school reform in terms of
being able to provide schools with a
greater autonomy in terms of setting
their curriculum mera targeting them so
that some issues were not lacking or can
be targeted so ever since we started in
our administration we have provided a
number of options that schools can
select from in terms of creating what we
call you have formative training plans
we started from history of course in our
city history is very important so we
call that projects based on memory I
just got back from a trip to Poland with
over 200 students where we went to visit
the Auschwitz concentration camp and
based on that we started a project which
is based on teacher training and teacher
updating in terms of working on what the
other cause was and
at a later stage as students have to
come up with a project it can be a video
object a camisa writing or work of art
and then we will show this to the entire
city through a an exhibit and we work on
many levels in what we call memory
projects and we did that with a number
of projects there are many events of the
19th of the 20th century for example we
went to Berlin on the anniversary of the
20th anniversary of the fatherland Wow
we are going to go to Prague later on in
terms of learning what happened in
Eastern Europe so overall we work to
reject any kind of totalitarian or
philosophy and we want to promote
critical thinking in our students we
believe very deeply in this so we don't
just want to educate an ax to our
students but we want for them to learn
to think independently I believe that
through these projects of these
initiatives and what we call an active
type of learning in our case based on on
history or you know recent a
contemporary history well we will
empower students also we're working on
projects to prevent social inequalities
and in particular we're working on
promoting ilysm episodes in Rome there
have been cases of vandalism in schools
or gang like attitudes in particular in
the lower-income neighborhoods so
together with the police forces that
that year worked with us on creating
products to accountability and were able
to promote new projects so we talked
about creating labs in schools in order
to include and I was interested too I
was interested in hearing what you were
saying about including that are not
traditionally part of the school system
running new partners external partners
that's exactly what we're doing in terms
of the prevention of violence and gang
like attitudes so the project will start
in the new school year creating networks
between give it you know enterprises and
schools and police force including
parents and teachers were just common
and I did likewise we are creating a
network at least on the incredible
historical and cultural and natural
resources of our city and through this
network our schools can really have a
great opportunities for active learning
because we can take children to visit
historical sites or natural parks they
are actually literally an hour footsteps
so and we also have any credible library
system that when we are making sure our
students get
I was to give also no problem once I
guys in line with what you have been
trying to we want to promote creativity
and a expression of individualism
through exhibits that were students and
experiment being antagonist of their own
lives and creation we have a project
called informa germany literally inform
young people and we are creating
activities for young people can be that
you create material that allows other
you're going to understand how the
workplace in our works to be scammed you
will love with us we can be more
projects also on from health in
particular we are working on our school
cafeterias in terms of numbers oye
provide 130,000 meals every day in our
schools preschools and also junior high
schools and high schools well yeah
junior High's like a 210 we provide a
very well-balanced menu and we use that
as an opportunity to promote nutritional
competence and I we focus on the
Mediterranean diet mediterranean-style
eating which was routinely identified by
UNESCO as
World Heritage so as I said earlier the
prevention of obesity is also promoted
through are not an innovative idea of
including tutors that specialize in
fitness and we've been doing that
starting from schools we allocated 3
million euros for these preschools so
that all families can have the
opportunity to take part in this fitness
program which i think is important in
terms of the creation of a more rounded
well-being based on what sports can do
in terms of promoting an assoc ality and
all those elements that were discussed
earlier today in terms of the project
that I was supposed to talk about here
today we are also focusing on the issue
of immigration and integration of
migrant populations because in recent
years we have had significant migration
trends in Rome we are in line with
national average that is a 4 / 9 percent
of the total particle population of
immigrant children but in Rome there was
a very it was an imbalance because
schools had much higher numbers of
non-italian students working others had
none so we said to blaze new initiatives
which we call local agreements in terms
of spreading
this kind of presence because we believe
that qualities of a non-italian children
is enrichment and we want for them to be
equally divided in all schools so this
project is leading to great results also
because we have had the opportunity to
experiment such initiatives and projects
in particular in preschools and we have
over 800 schools between this year three
and three to five year old schools and
preschools and I believe that these
kinds of schools are ideally suited to
reach our target of inserting migrant
populations in the school system and I
also believe that all these actions
targeted integration it started very
early in the early childhood years well
they can lead to a much deeper
integration thank you very much I'm for
questions if you'd like to ask a
question make a comment please come up
to the mic and identify yourself thank
you very much for your presentation I'm
my name is distros our from Tokyo my
sorry for my poor english my present job
is mainly focused on teachers training
with respect to ICT such as smart board
projectors and we have already spent 40
million dollars to set all those things
to metropolitan high schools
according to the survey we did this year
more than twenty percent of teachers
have been hesitating to use those things
in his or her lessons and I'd like to
ask you how the role of teachers has
been changed or not with ICT or if so
how and more I think sometimes students
have much more knowledge than teachers
so how about so-called they still
divided is there any kind of that among
teachers or even in the students I mean
one thing I found right away is that and
I meant to say this but it's very
different talking to adults than
children get a little nervous the
students are so excited just excited to
have the technology in the classroom and
even more than them is the parents so
anytime you can have the parents
witnessed the smartboard being used when
we did our first open house my
third-grade colleague and I presented to
the parents on the smartboard and we had
them everybody's taking pictures with
their cell phone because they felt so
excited that this is what their children
that third graders would be leaving the
classroom note with a real knowledge of
Technology and expectation of Technology
so I think a lot of teachers are
hesitant myself I don't know how to use
it so you have to make sure we have
someone in the building who is a
technology specialist who's in my room
several times a day it's a model for me
how to use it and to assist me when
things go wrong it's it's difficult
because it's new and I think it's about
convincing teachers that it actually
makes less work for us to use the
technology let me ask well if there's
other question someone else can come to
Mike
are the teachers in your startup schools
they're sort of self selected in so
they're already enthusiastic and is that
part of the phase-in strategy is to is
to get some proselytizers out there who
are confident about think it's a
combination i shared with with Arthur at
the beginning that every year in my
first years at this school they said
this woman do you want a smart board and
I said no thank you can take it across
the hall and this is the first this is
the third year I've been offered one the
first year i've taken in it was
absolutely because i was afraid i didn't
know how to use it and um I've
definitely had to rely on the children a
lot always telling me don't be nervous
you'll be fine you can do so I think a
lot of it is just really having that
conversation that is it is something new
and it is something to help us but I
think it's a combination and I myself
was definitely someone who said no thank
you so that knowing I have the support
to do it and again actually having
enough of the tools to make it something
that we can use I think encouraged but
many people are on board because looking
around this morning as people were
talking everyone had some kind of device
in their hand so yes hi my name is Cindy
carbon network leader and I was just
wondering from a school design or
curriculum design perspective what
surprised you that you needed to teach
students and what I was thinking about
was you both of you mentioned that
students were doing research did you
find that you had to do a lot of
research scaffolding for students or did
they know how to do that and the same
with teachers what skills did the
teachers not have that surprised you and
it's a little bit different than just
the technology because both of you
talked about the pedagogy in terms of
that the center of what the kids are
doing is about thinking so just if you
can talk to that a little bit our first
big surprise was that our kids don't
know how to read online that you give
them
text on paper and once I've got into
high school most of them have developed
some level of skill at decoding that
text to make sense for comprehension and
you give them that same text online and
they have nothing and so we have to
teach 14 year olds who can read on a 14
year old level or on a 16 year old level
how to read online and that takes most
kids a few months to learn how to
transfer their decoding skills and it
has to be consciously taught the other
thing we teach much more explicitly than
we ever thought we would teach was
metacognition and when teaching kids
online they have to learn at a much
higher level when they know something
and there's not there's not as much of
the adult feedback and even though we
have online graded quizzes and whatnot
in a traditional classroom the teacher
tells you when you know something and
when you're ready to move on and in a
self-paced online course that is very on
some level student driven and they have
to know when am I ready to take the
summative tests on this section so I can
see if I can move on in and teaching
kids to know that accurately it is a
huge part of what we do now of course we
do teach research skills but I've never
been in a school where we didn't teach
research skills I mean I feel like we
have to we don't assume students know
anything but they know I do it and that
we have to teach a lot um I think also a
question about technology is it whenever
you're hiring teachers teachers every
teacher even the best teacher we hire is
going to need growth in some area and so
as a school leader hiring teachers we
have to decide where do we want to focus
our instruction with teachers and to me
it's much easier to teach a teacher how
to use a smart board then it t is to
teach a teacher to believe that kids can
learn from working together and
struggling with a problem and learn that
way so we hire very much to a belief
about how students learn and then with
the notion that we will have to teach
them how to use the technology
integrate the technology and and in fact
that's for us much easier to teach hi my
name is Rafael Parenti from you John
Daly Brazil and actually my mind it's a
it's more a request than a question
because we also have been building a
learning platform online platform with
digital classes that we have been
testing some schools the results have
been very positive and starting februari
we're going to start projecting the
activities the videos and games and
quizzes and everything on the classrooms
of 420 classrooms in Rio and all the
content is there in this platform but
what we're thinking is within this
platform we need to have a kind of a
formative assessment just like when a
kid plays wii sports tennis for example
and he's playing but at the same time
you have a graph being built there
because there is an intelligence behind
a system that says if the student that
is using that system is doing ok or not
if he's developing those abilities or
not how well he's doing right and also
if we can insert some kind of game based
or project based on filling and
characteristic to these platforms then
perhaps we're going to have a great
thing because what we want to do is we
want to have our kids engaged and
addicted to learning right so my
question is if you know New York City
the Department of Education perhaps
other partners would be able and would
like to keep on sharing because I know
that we're going to see a platform
because you know we you talk but we we
kind of try to visualize old how does
that go what what kind of what kind of
environmental they do they go into what
do they experiment you know it's very
enriching to hear you talking about the
experience but I'm trying to visualize
the systems and the platforms and
you know I I know that many of them are
based on licensed and software is very
naughty and others but as long as
possible perhaps we could continue
exchanging experience about these
platforms and perhaps even sharing
platforms among you know different
cities and different countries Leumi are
in in Brazil and yet in top bottle and
using we're very interested to learn
more about that platform actually
because I think it has a lot in mosaic
platform has a lot of these kind of
competency-based progressions and being
able to tag content learning activities
digital resources and performance tests
to that so that's I think that's the
kind of the next generation platform
that we are trying to engage the
industry in moving toward that is not
tightly integrated around a single
vendors solution or a single kind of
assessment like multiple choice
assessment but allowing a variety of
different kinds of assessment to
contribute to definitions of mastery
project-based challenge based portfolio
based as well as multiple choice giving
that formative progress so where we're
trying to kind of express our
requirements out to the industry and
partners to try to push in that
direction but we're looking for
innovative models we've discovered what
we saw in mosaic and very interested in
continuing the conversation so I think
the ending to fall on the exchange of
information and the interest in
continuing the exchange is a good place
to end this session let's thank the
panelists
you